there has not been
um an actor that I get more messages
about from just the people I work with
than you all ages all Races everything
genders do you remember the first time
you realized how much of a loyal
following you had
um I know well thank you uh
you know what I I think it speaks to
the films that I've been fortunate
enough to be a part of
you know I got to be a part of early in
my career super early even like a
picture called River's Edge or you know
more popular maybe Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure you know that unique
story or do an action picture you know
like Point Break you know to do a
picture like speed and then to work with
the wachowskis on The Matrix you know to
get to play John Constantine I mean I'm
working with amazing artists and stories
you know and
these directors and people in studios
sometimes have agreed to let me be a
part of telling these stories so
I feel a part of it but I'm also like
you know I'm a part of it yeah you know
so if someone appreciates what I'm doing
then
you know thank you and when did I first
build that yeah I mean you kind of get
it when people say lines back to you I I
wanted to come in and say something you
know what I mean like reach hurry up
just get to the point if someone says
Hey when the first time Reeves someone
sees you and says be excellent you're
like okay that might be the beginning
you know be excellent you know even with
like so I've been in a lot of films
where someone I am an FBI agent you know
I am an FBI agent this has given me so
much life you know what I mean like yes
Utah give me two Utah
give me two two you know I mean so I
don't know people are gonna love that
just seeing you reenact those man it's
bananas it's bananas what is what true
what truth
you know morphe I mean so I've been a
part of some films that I've had some
pretty cool lines
I want you to find your peace but the
good death
only comes after a good life
[Music]
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend whenever Keanu there
is any sort of announcement clip trailer
about this movie The fandom loses its
mind why do you think that the fans go
so hard for John Wick
um I don't know I mean I love John Wick
I love playing it I love playing the
character I love the world of John Wick
uh chapter 4 is so ambitious
um the director chats to helski you know
had such an expansive vision for the
film we have so many new characters
um and I think John Wick has a different
flavor yes you know it has a different
I don't know it feels authentic in a way
you know what I mean it still has that
independent movie Spirit true and
they're fun and I feel like John Wick
gives the audience a hug like come on in
come along for the ride
buckle up you're gonna see some action
it's gonna be funny there's gonna be
some ideas you know rules consequences
surviving getting knocked down get back
up you know
um fight for your freedom go against the
man you know so there's a lot of things
that we can relate to I feel and also
just the costumes the cinema they look
beautiful this movie was beautiful yeah
it really really was is there another
role for you with this much enthusiasm
is it the Matrix was it did you feel
that's this kind of fervor from the
fandom oh from the fans yeah I mean
definitely um you know I could say that
yes there's some Matrix yeah kind of
appreciation which is such a
such a special thing yeah you know for
me and also you know we're just trying
to make good movies if not great movies
you know and you know it's cool when
people like them you think your wife can
hear you
no
a white bottle
Maybe I'm Wrong
[Music]
maybe not what do your fans mean to you
gosh uh
I don't know I mean you're making them
but it's selfish right I'm getting to do
what I love I'm getting I'm getting to
play
you know and I'm getting to meet and
work with such wonderful artists and
people and I'm so grateful for that but
ultimately what are we doing there you
know we're telling stories and
I know for me how I love movies
um
I appreciate it when I watch a great
movie or a good movie and I'm really
happy that I'm getting to do that you
know and so if I can be a part of giving
that to because I'm not here within out
an audience right absolutely and I don't
complete the circle of being in the
storytelling frame without an audience
and so
that's uh what is yes
you know can I ask you quickly about
ballerina I know you guys already shot
it yeah um and you are in it yeah I
played John Wick in this film being
directed by Len Wiseman called ballerina
with Anna deharmus why was she the
perfect person to kind of take this
franchise into the next chat
um I think because she's an amazing
artist and
um you know the story was you know
existed in in this artist kind of was a
wonderful fit for it and they wanted to
do it like Anna was
you know excited to do it and you know
when I met her you know Len really
really you know had a lot of
conversations with Chad and and loves
the John Wick um movies so he took that
in and then working with him he had his
own Vision as well you know so it's like
I love that painting I'm gonna be
influence that painting but now I'm
going to draw that painting you know and
Anna was like I love that painting but
I'm gonna go make that my own and so it
was cool to like be in someone else's
painting but to be a paint
in that landscape
[Music]